Hola contestadora automática, mi vieja amiga.
(Risas)
He llamado a servicio técnico de nuevo.
Ignoré la advertencia de mi jefe. Llamé un Lunes por la mañana.
Ahora anochece, y mi cena primero se enfrió-- y luego se enmoheció.
Todavía sigo en espera. Estoy escuchando los sonidos del silencio.
No creo que me hayas entendido. Digo que nadie está atendiendo.
Ya he presionado cada tecla que me han indicado.
Y aún así he pasado 18 horas en espera.
No es suficiente que su software haya arruinado mi Mac y...
esta constantemente se traba y fracasa. ¡Ha borrado mis ROMs! Ahora mi Mac...
Hace el sonido del silencio.
En mi sueños fantaseo
dar rienda suelta a mi venganza contra ustedes.
Supongamos que choquen en motocicleta
sangre salpica de sus heridas. Con tu fuerza debilitandose
llamas al 911 y rezas por un paramédico entrenado. Pero en eso llego yo.
(Risas)
Y tu escuchas el sonido... del silencio.
(Aplausos)
Gracias. Buena tarde y bienvenidos a
"Conozca al Presentador de TED que alguna vez fue Músico de Broadway"
(Risas)
Bien. Cuando me ofrecieron la columna del Times hace seis años,
el trato fue este: Se te enviarán los mas atractivos, modernos e ingeniosos gadgets.
Cada semana llegarán a tu casa.
Deberás probarlos, jugar con ellos, evaluarlos
hasta que pase la novedad, pero antes tendrás que devolverlos.
Y te pagaremos por eso. Piénsalo y nos avisas.
Entonces, siempre he sido un fanático de la tecnología y la adoro.
el trabajo, sin embargo, tenía una pequeña desventaja. Y era que
intentaron agregar mi email al final de cada columna publicada.
Y lo que he notado es... primero que todo, que recibo una cantidad increible de correos electrónicos.
Si alguna vez te sientes solo
hazte de una columna en el New York Times, porque tendrás miles y
miles y miles de emails. Y el mensaje que recibo a menudo
es de acerca de la frustración.
La gente siente que las cosas - OK
Tengo una alarma saliendo en mi pantalla. Por suerte no la pueden ver.
La gente se siente abrumada. Sienten que es demasiada tecnología, demasiado rápido.
Puede ser buena tecnología.
pero siento que no hay suficiente estructura de soporte.
No hay sufiente ayuda. No hay suficiente análisis
dedicado al diseño de las cosas para hacerlas fáciles y divertidas de usar.
Cierta ocasión, escribí una columna sobre mis esfuerzos para contactar
al Servicio Técnico de Dell. Y tras 12 horas,
habían 700 comentarios en el artículo publicado
en el sitio web del Times, de usuarios diciendo: "¡Me pasó lo mismo!"
"He vivido la misma desgracia." Yo llamo a esto ira de software.
Y permítanme decirles, quien logre sacar dinero
de estas frustraciones...
Oh, ¿Cómo llegó esto acá? Solo bromeo.
(Risas)
Ok, Entonces. ¿Por qué este problema esta acelerándose? Y parte del problema es
irónicamente, porque los fabricantes han puesto tanto análisis
en facilitar el uso de las cosas.
Les enseñaré de lo que hablo
Así es como el entorno de una computadora se veía, DOS.
Con los años, se ha vuelto mas fácil de usar.
Este es el sistema operativo original de Mac.
Reagan era Presidente. Madonna todavía era morena.
Y todo el sistema operativo -
ésta es la parte buena--el sistema operativo completo, cabía en 211 kb
Ahora no se puede ni poner el logo del sistema Mac10 en 211kb.
(Risas)
Así que lo irónico es que, mientras éstas cosas se volvían más fáciles de usar
una comunidad menos preparada y más amplia estaba entrando en contacto
con estos equipos por primera vez.
Una vez, tuve el privilegio de visitar el centro de atención al cliente de Apple por un día.
Un tipo tenía doble auricular, para yo poder escuchar.
Y recibía llamadas -- ustedes saben como son...
"Su llamada puede estar siendo grabada para asegurar la calidad de servicio."
Mm-Mmm. Su llamada puede ser grabada
de modo que se puedan recopilar las más divertidas historias de usuarios tontos
y luego compartirlas en un CD.
(Risas)
Lo cual realmente hacen.
Y yo tengo una copia.
(Risas)
Hay una en sus bolsas de regalo. No, no.
Con sus voces en ella.
Así que, algunas historias son tan clásicas, y aún así comprensibles
Una mujer llamó a Apple para quejarse
que su mouse (ratón) estaba chillando - haciendo un sonido chillón.
Y el técnico le dijo, "Bien señora, ¿A qué se refiere con chillando?"
Ella dice, "Todo lo que le puedo decir es que
chilla mas fuerte entre mas lo arrastro por la pantalla".
(Risas)
Y el técnido confundido, "Señora, ¿Está arrastrando el contra ratón sobre la pantalla?"
Ella responde, "Bueno, el mensaje decía 'Click aquí para continuar' "
(Risas)
Si les gustó esa historia, ¿Cuánto tiempo nos queda?
Una más. Un tipo llamó, esto es verídico!
Su computadora se había trabado, y le dijo al técnico que
no podía reiniciarla sin importar cuántas veces tecleara 11.
Y el técnico le dijo "¿Qué? ¿Por qué está tecleando 11?"
"Es que el mensaje dice 'Error de escritura 11' "
(Risas)
Así que hay que admitir que algunos de estos errores son totalmente culpa de los usuarios.
Pero, ¿Por qué es la crisis de sobrecarga técnica,
la crisis de la complejidad, acelerándose ahora? En el mundo del hardware
esto se debe a que los consumidores quieren todo más pequeño, más pequeño, más pequeño.
Así que los aparatos se vuelven más pequeños y más pequeños
pero nuestros dedos se mantienen esencialmente del mismo tamaño.
Así que se vuelve más y más un reto.
Los programas son materia de otra fuerza primaria:
la obligación de lanzar más y más versiones.
Cuando compramos un programa, no es como comprar artesanía
o un caramelo, dónde es tuyo.
Es más bien como unirse a un club donde pagas cuotas cada año.
Y cada año te dicen,
"Hemos agregado nuevas características y se las venderemos por 99 dólares"
Yo conozco a una persona que gastó 4000 dolares sólo en Photoshop en algunos años.
Y las compañías desarrolladoras hacen 35% de sus ingresos
sólo de estas actualizaciones a sus programas.
Yo lo llamo La Paradoja de las Actualizaciones de Programas--
lo cual significa que, si actualizas un programa suficientes veces,
eventualmente terminas aruinándolo.
Digo, Microsoft Word era al final sólo un procesador de texto en, ya saben,
desde la administración Eisenhower.
(Risas)
Pero, ¿Cuál era la alternativa? Microsoft en realidad hizo un experimento, dijeron,
"Bien,espera un minuto. Todo el mundo se queja que estamos agregando muchas funciones
vamos a crear un procesador de texto que sea sólo un procesador de texto
simple, puro, que no haga páginas web, ni maneje bases de datos".
Y lo lanzaron. Y fue bautizado Microsoft Write.
Y ninguno de ustedes esta asintiendo en reconocimiento, porque murió.
Se estancó. Nadie nunca lo compró.
Yo llamo a esto "El Principio de la Ostentación de Utilidad". A la gente le gusta rodearse
de poder innecesario, ¿cierto?
Ellos no necesitan de bases de datos o páginas web, pero son como...
"Pues voy a actualizarme, porque, algún día, quien sabe, quizás necesite esto."
Así que el problema es, que si agregas mas funciones ¿Dónde las vas a poner?
¿Dónde las vas a colocar? Sólo hay cierta cantidad de herramientas de diseño.
Puedes hacer botones, pestañas, menús emergentes, sub menús.
Pero si no tienes cuidado al escojer, vas a terminar con algo así...
(Risas)
Esto es una no retocada - No es broma - no retocada foto de Microsoft Word.
la copia que ustedes usan, con todas las barras abiertas.
Ustedes obviamente nunca abren todas las barras.
Pero todo el lugar para escribir es esta pequeña, mínima ventana de aquí.
(Risas)
Pero hemos llegado a la edad de los entornos matriciales, donde hay
tantas funciones y opciones, que tienes que hacer dos dimensiones, saben.
Una vertical y otra horizontal. Y todos se quejan al respecto.
Como Microsoft Word siempre está enumerando listas y subrrayando los emails.
El switch de apagado está allí, en algún lado.
¡Se los digo, está allí!
Parte de diseñar una interface agradable y sencilla
está en saber cuando usar cada función.
Miremos, esto aparece en el cierre de sesión de Windows 2000
Solo existen 4 opciones.
Entonces ¿Por qué están metidas en un menú despelgable?
No es como sí el resto de la pantalla esté saturada de componentes,
para que sea necesario amontonar las opciones.
Pudieron haberlas puesto a simple vista.
Aquí está la misma situación pero para Apple.
(Aplausos)
Gracias - Si, yo diseñe esta caja de dialogo. No, no, no.
Ya, podemos ver como Apple y Microsoft
están abismalmente distanciados en diseño de software.
El acercamiento de Microsoft a simplicidad, tiende a ser:
Desarmemos esto, pongamos más pasos para todo.
Están los ayudantes para cualquier cosa.
Y ya saben que hay una nueva versión de Windows lista para el otoño.
Si continúan a este paso, no hay manera de adivinar
dónde van a terminar.
(Aplausos)
Bienvenido al Ayudante para Escribir la Letra A. Ok, picaré. Vamós a hacer click en continuar.
(aplausos)
Del menú desplegable, escoja la primera letra que desea escribir. Bien.
(Risas)
Así que hay un límite al que no queremos llegar. ¿Cuál es la solución?
¿Cómo juntar todas estás funciones en una forma simple e inteligente?
Yo creo que es posible cuando hay consistencia.
equivalentes en el mundo real, eliminar carpetas usualmente, etiquetar la mayoría de cosas.
Pero le ruego a los diseñadores que paren
todas esas reglas si violan la mayor regla de todas.
que es la inteligencia ¿A qué me refiero con esto?
Daré unos ejemplos donde la inteligencia hace algo
que no parece consistente,pero da mejores resultados.
Si estás comprando algo en internet, se deben dar datos como la dirección y
uno debe escojer en que país vive, ¿cierto?
Existen 200 paises en el mundo. Nos gusta pensar en Internet como una red global.
Lo siento, todavía no lo es.
Es básicamente, Estados Unidos, Europa y Japón
Entonces, ¿Por qué Estados Unidos (United States) está en la U?
(Risas)
Uno debe bajar como 7 pantallas para llegar a la U.
Ahora, sería inconsistente poner United States de primero,
pero sería inteligente. Está es otra muy mencionada pero,
Por Dios, ¿Por qué para apagar la computadora debemos dar click en el botón
llamado "Inicio"?
(Risas)
Aquí hay otra de mis favoritas: Usted tiene una impresora,
la mayoría de veces solo va a imprimir una copia del documento,
en el orden normal, en la misma impresora.
Entonces, ¿Por qué diantres tenemos esta pantalla cada vez que vamos a imprimir?
Es como la cabina de piloto de un 747.
(Risas)
Y uno de los botones al final,notarán, no es "Imprimir."
(Aplausos)
Ahora, no digo que Apple sea la única compañia comprometida
al culto de la simplicidad.
Palm es también, especialmente hace algún tiempo, magnifíco en esto.
Justamente tuve la oportunidad de hablar en Palm en sus momentos de auge en los 90s.
y luego de hablarles, conocí a uno de los empleados.
Dijo, "Buena charla" Y yo dije; "Gracias, ¿Cuál es tu trabajo?"
El dijo, "Soy un contador de golpes"
Quedé "¿Qué tu qué?" El dijo "Pues, Jeff Hawkins, el Gerente dijo
'Si cualquier tarea en la Palm de prueba se toma mas de 3 golpes del lápiz
es demasiado larga, y tiene que ser rediseñada'. Entonces, yo soy el contador de golpes"
Así que les mostraré un ejemplo de una compañia que no tiene
un contador de golpes
Esto es Microsoft Word, ok. Cuando quieres crear un nuevo documento en blanco,
¡Podría pasar!
(Risas)
Vas al menu Archivo y escojes Nuevo, bien.
¿Qué pasa al escojer Nuevo? ¿Obtienes tu documento nuevo?
No, claro que no.
Al lado opuesto del monitor, aparece una barra de tareas, y en algún lugar,
en esos enlaces, -por cierto no el primero- en algún lugar en esos enlaces
está el botón que te hace un nuevo documento.
Bien, esa es una empresa que no cuenta los golpes.
Saben, no quiero estár aca sólo burlándome de Microsoft.
Público: ¡Sigue!
David Pogue: Si, seguiré.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)